[Music]
today we're gonna look at the game as I
played in the Friday action quads many
people asked me why I lost in round
three well I mean you can't really
expect this a Bubba B Priyadarshan so I
had a pretty good tournament I think
okay
round one I played my student Matt
Larson and we had just had a lesson
earlier that day so we played in round
one okay so as many of you know in this
audience but not in that audience
the Friday action quads had added a lot
of prizes to the prizes so we're playing
and then I didn't win but I tried and I
feel miserably the lesson is never try
okay it was a Sicilian okay now I heard
a long speech about Sicilians today that
I'm sure is apropos for this class oh
wait a minute no it's not I guess I
would be an eggplant if I said that okay
so we'll go beyond the true romance
speech about Sicilian and we'll talk
about my favorite Sicilian Sicilian
pizza oh that is good you know okay now
there's a grandmaster in the United
States
who is quite good and his name has got a
calm ski and of all the top players in
the world the only person to play like I
did has got a Calm ski so you got to
give him some credit in this position
99.9 percent of the game's white plays
Knight takes d4 the so-called open
Sicilian and I played Queen takes d4
which is I guess another Grandmaster
likes it Grandmaster Ken West and that's
Grandmaster
Kendall Hester okay so the idea behind
Queen sakes well for me the ideas that
got a theory but the actual idea is that
white castles Queen side very quickly
now I did a lot of preparation for Mark
Esserman in this line and that's one of
the few games I play and I also give a
lecture a few months ago where I beat
Tommy all
in the Chicago open and all of those
games including this one black played
Knight to c6 oh wait a minute Tommy
didn't play Knight to c6 nevermind 96 is
the most common move after Knight c6 I'm
gonna go back in a second
if you move your queen away because your
Queens attacked then you probably
shouldn't have taken with the Queen
because you keep moving your Queen like
some people we know and if I don't move
my queen then he'll take my queen then I
may even is it all be mad so so I played
Bishop to b5 this is a very common
tactic when you move your queen into the
middle because the Knights going to
attack your queen and you pin the knight
notice to robert Hess's dismay three
years I've been doing that joke Knight
takes Queen is illegal okay well when
Robert Hess was lecturing here three
years ago whenever he made an illegal
move it made a really loud noise he's
like it's kind of turn that off so
whenever I make it a legal move I make
fun of Robert house okay well he plays
for a team called the dreadknots so I
should make fun of them right okay it's
true okay so you know those dailies they
they are they hardly beat us in football
half the time now going back some
players play a six and now it's obvious
why they do that
that's tough it should be five so the
knight c6 will key in a tempo okay so 96
and then unpin take take Knight c3
Knight f6 here and now everybody plays
east six because this Bishop can't move
and they want to move their Bishop right
okay but and I have I have games on that
line my opponent played h6 attacking my
bishop but I saw it
now let's vote when somebody plays h6
should you take their knight in double
their pawns or just go back who says
take the knight yeah okay who says go
back okay so
okay so if you did not double your
opponents pawns then I would play Bishop
h4 because then I'm still pinning the
knight or something but since I'm going
to double the pawns anyway then h6
doesn't really do anything this is sort
of a wasted move fact I would argue the
pawns better on h7 because after ggf the
bishop doesn't have the age six square
okay
and now I Castle which is what I said I
was going to do and I have all my pieces
out of my castle and black has one piece
out and has not castled and cannot
castle and if black does cast I'll
probably made them because where's he
gonna Castle okay maybe the safest place
would be over here but I mean black
can't really castle there okay so my
opponent I thought would play e6 and
then that defends all the squares and
actually this I could show this game in
the next lecture okay I have an electric
coming up after this one and this game
is apropos for that lecture also it's a
rich tapestry so a6 which I thought was
slow and b5 which I thought was slow now
my opponent who was also my student I
have had a lesson with him since this
game and he says he was better later
because his computer says so so he's
right okay now I wanted to play 95 but I
noticed that was risky and then I wanted
to play 9 g5 and notice that was risky
and the one square between e5 and g5 is
f5 but even though I'm a grandmaster I
still can't do that
Robert has maybe so I played what move
Isabel how do I get my cover
A to F sank do it can I take my queen
and then go there so where can it go yes
Isabel yes I always caught Isabel
because she has the same first name I do
9 H 4
okay and some people say that move
stinks pause for effect because it's NH
4 BAM okay
somebody explain that choked Isabel
please do you know chemistry yet now yet
well in a few years you'll start
laughing
I know that's good that's that's good
that's a good straight and head over
there
perfect timing you'll get paid extra
tonight okay so now I'm gonna play
Knight f5 or as Greek Grandmaster Vasily
as catalonia's would say knife f5
he likes Knight a5 okay so Rick ga cuz
there looks better on this open line
then on h8 at Knight f5 so if I was
doing an outpost lecture for example
which I'm doing in about 45 minutes I
would say those Knights have good
outposts now this is something very
interesting this reminds me of blackjack
when you go to the casino and you play
blackjack often you have two choices or
as my dad would say one choice and one
alternative you can hit or you can stay
and there's also other choices but let's
not get too complicated here now when a
lot of people will stay when they should
hit and the reason is when they hit
sometimes they lose and they don't want
to lose now that's a very suspicious
mathematical way to figure the situation
out fact that is a mathematical way so
if you have two choices and one's bad it
doesn't mean you do the other one it
means you look at the other one and you
compare them and do the better one so my
opponent made a bad move and when I
asked him why he didn't make the better
move he said that looked risky and I
said it is risky and your move is risky
but it doesn't win upon my moves risking
it wins upon so the obvious move is rook
takes g2 then Black is up upon and then
I thought I would play rook g1 for
example and if we traded rooks which he
probably shouldn't do then I would play
rook g8 later and probably White's
better that was a joke because White's a
lot better okay but probably he could
play something like rook g6 and try to
be solid now he was he was his a
computer of course agreed with me his
computer said rook take g2 and blacks
fine but black would be a part of if he
took on g2 but he was afraid to do that
so he played here g6 now in his game is
not very good and he's not a pawn up so
okay so why did he play rook g6 I assume
he wants to play e6 working my Knights
but if he played that last move then
white has a slight advantage yeah then
you know that's so good for black okay
so rook g6 sort of okay so then I played
h4 and my idea was if he played six I
would play h5 and his rook is worth more
than my knight and if his rook moves
away this is still good so he played h5
I believe yes and I played f3 now my
plan was to play g4 that's why I played
f3 and my other plan after east six was
to play Knight to b4 and I'm attacking
his Bishop and I'm attacking his d6 pawn
and his King's really well placed okay
so he played Bishop takes d5 which I
thought was bad and his computer said he
should have played that every move like
the last move this moved the move before
and I took and I was like wow that's a
great night and that's a bad Bishop okay
so man I can't make that joke even
thinking about that joke I should good I
should get a job here and get fired okay
so so so rook c8 was played putting the
rook on the open line and now I decided
to Queens was better than one but it was
a tough decision okay so I decided this
pawn could Queen accept this pawns in
the way so I played g4 and he said thank
you
and I called the director and I said
he's talking during the game age five
age six age seven not when he blocked it
no but I liked the way he played rook g8
to g6 to GA to H a he showed me that he
castled later and I resigned yeah okay
now he's threatening pawn takes tonight
but I saw it Queenie for preventing pawn
takes Knight and threatening Queen takes
c6 Chuck he developed a piece does he
have a lot of development develop the
King f7 he developed a piece now now the
computer says I should play some crazy
but I played Knight d4 attacking his
East six pawn he saw it and I took now
material is equal but I have a passed
pawn on the seventh rank and his King is
ridiculous so he's completely losing
here and I could win easier by sacking
all my pieces but I didn't do that okay
now you'll notice I'm threatening rook
g6 check with advantage okay and this is
shocking to everyone especially me he
played the move I expected but nobody
would expect this move I don't know why
I expected it what did black play to
stop rook to g6 Chuck King e5 because
you saw the game very good right now
Rick g6 is risky cuz my nights hanging
so I defended by night and he played the
move I expected came to d5 he's trying
to run away and then he's still losing
probably because I have passed pawn in
the 7th right ok so now I played rook to
g6 threatening his East six pawn and he
blundered although computer says he's
like - a million sometimes - 2 million
he played rook to e8 and now I have a
winning tactic which Grandmaster Ken
West will now show remember it's a
tactic so it's like some capture you
grandma Esther Ken West win close if you
knew the names of the squares you'd show
your twin which is she's 7 yeah I know
who the evil twin is okay rook takes 6
now rook takes 6 is risky because Queen
takes f5 check let's check and if rookie
5 Queen takes Queen is good for white
and if King see 4 which is the other
legal move Knight takes c6 white is
ahead material and threatening made
everywhere like mate and possibly this
is me but I'm not sure it looks like
it's made and he's done a lot of
material so he didn't do that
so after rook takes six any good player
would resign but he played you incorrect
that everything works yeah but mine
moves much better and I'm not even
kidding because the goal of chess which
Julian doesn't know yet because
intermediate is checkmate the King
you'll notice the King can't go back but
if you play 966 than the King just runs
away and black wins
okay so rook takes c6 his King can't I
can't move here because Robert has said
so okay so Bishop g7 defending his rook
check and now I think knight c6 is the
computer move with the idea Knight a5
and rook h4 but I did the sea knight c6
I wanted to play b3 mate except b3 is
not made even though ken west thought it
was because he likes b3 okay then c3
pawn is hanging so I played King c2
threatening b3 mate Grand Master Ken
West I got was an easy question why it's
threatening mate how do you stop it
because you don't want to get mated no
no he stopped or without resigning see
your influence is inefficacious
right Isabel see all you got to do is
stop meeting one in your gold b3 mate
how do you stop it who wants to help
there you go help well then I'm gonna
I'm gonna play be three million yeah
still me
d5 is one way not too good and the way
he played Bishop e5 the idea is you're
giving your King shelter a lot Rolling
Stones okay which also didn't work out
well for them now I played the simple
tactic rook takes e5 taking a bishop
threatening b3 mate defending my queen
he resigned if he takes my queen with
Chuck I can't play Magus I'm in Chuck
but I can take threatening mate and I'm
a piece up
so he resigned here and his time ran out
and I declared made and martial law was
declared and so forth okay terrible okay
and that game I actually won now my next
game was very suspicious that's the way
I like it okay so the next game I played
Tyler Hughes as many of you know he's a
PhD student at Wash U for those of you
new in town Washington University okay
also it's not 6440 it's 40 and people
here have issues yeah
and also they say Creve Coeur what else
do they do wrong let's see well
everything basically okay so also st.
Louis come on right now you know what
I'm talking about
okay so Tyler Hughes played in the u.s.
championship in this very building
before I worked here the first one they
had in 2009 but I wasn't here so I
didn't do it now Tyler's not playing
competitively anymore but since we upped
the prizes in the Friday action quad and
play competitively okay so I'm black I
played my usual blocked benoni which I
gave a lecture on about two three four
months ago plus tax
I gave a lecture on like unlike this
position and my opponent played g3 and
we had this boring you know world of
Niels Bohr okay and yeah I Castle okay
age four so he's not kidding around cuz
it's an action tournament
okay h4 actually I think is a good move
somehow so there's no theory and the
center is blocked so we get to play
chess very early and normally I get a
big time advantage because I make all
these moves really quickly
maybe my games not good but I've more
time and probably that's more important
in a game 25 tournament although as I've
been in Foreman's game 26 so my opponent
wants to play h5 now I can show you many
games where my opponent plays h5 and I
play Knight h8
but I didn't feel like at this game so I
played Knight h5 he played Queen c2
which is a good move because he's gonna
do some stuff
to me here and he's gonna probably
Castle queenside in fact he did all that
stuff and I played Bishop d7 and he
played Knight g5 now if I take a pawn
which is pretty greedy rook takes
tonight would normally win a knight
except his queen would take my ruck I
hate when that happens
so there's a there's a little tactic
called removing the guard and what is
guarding the knight the Queen so what
move can white make to attack the Queen
and make the Queen move away from the
knight there's two good answers but one
answer is slightly better than the other
slightly
yeah Bishop c1 now you four is probably
good too but Bishop c1 is annoying
okay and I don't want to get checkmated
on each side okay so I played Queen is
c8 and here was my idea I thought he
would play Bishop to f3 attacking my
knight
so I played Queen c8 and my idea was if
he plays Bishop f3 I'll play Bishop g4
and my other idea was to take on b4 and
then my queen is putting pressure on c4
after Queen CA my opponent thought a
long time Isabel do you know what it's
called when the Queen and Bishop are
lined up on the same diagonal that's
correct
well she didn't know that's right
Grandmaster a battery very good okay he
knew amazing that's why he's a
grandmaster okay so my opponent played
b5 now I took on pissant
that's another class actually not this
one okay
so now I can't really do that now I
don't like my rook here and I'm gonna
tell you why at some point I would like
to play f5 because that looks good but
if I ever play a move like that let's
play it now he would play 96 notice my
pawns not here anymore
uh-huh and then if I take the knight on
the outpost then when he takes back my
rook is hanging and his Knight has
another outpost so if I ever want to
play
f-five then I probably shouldn't have my
rook here because this bishop will
eventually take my rook so I played a
six and Casey castles Queen side and he
took and I took and I my rooks not there
and he played Bishop f3 attacking my
knight but I saw it and I played Bishop
g4 as I explained earlier he played
Bishop b4 which was quite annoying so he
has a lot of pressure on h7 I played f5
as I explained earlier and he went back
now he can play f3 trapping my bishop or
96 do you know why he didn't play either
one of those moves can West correct it's
not his turn otherwise he would have
played both I played f4 stopping
everything and he played 94 because I
give him the e4 square for his night and
we traded and now do I resign now now I
didn't want my King on this open
diagonal so I played King h8 I mean I
played Bishop f5 and then I played King
h8 I almost remember the game and he
castled which is a little iffy in my
opinion rook to a4 and Queen a6
attacking the c4 pawn hooray and I think
he played 92 yeah and I played b5 and is
this where he played them if I didn't
see or that was next to move his next
move yeah efore yes yes Knight where
for who while you're black okay on g3
yeah but I go yeah why you're giving a
lot of pieces away which I did later I
gave more pieces away later
there is laughing when I won someone you
guy won not really
everybody's laughing like how'd you win
you get all your pieces away like I won
me alone it's a blitz game okay so at
b5e for b4 and I missed the most obvious
move for white which is Queen f3 and I
know he took took Queen f3 I lose all my
pieces now I lose this and I lose this
if I lose that I get mated yeah I didn't
see Queen f3
so me and now I was thinking I was gonna
lose although not really but I should
lose I sacrificed all my pieces as you
recommend now he probably should play
Knight b1 but okay he took probably also
good and then I played rook to c8
sacrificing my king side so I could get
some checkmating attack although if I
put this on a computer engine it's going
to laugh at me but I didn't do that
he played Queen b3 and I saved my bishop
and I played Bishop a4 missing that in
this position he could play Queen takes
pawn I didn't see Queen takes pawn
because if his Queen moves somewhere
else I could probably take this okay so
now I'm down a lot of material and my
rook is hanging so it's time to give up
more material
ix a g3 he took my rook 92 check see I
got a lot of checks for my two or three
rooks a lot of checks see look I checked
him yay okay I'm down a lotta material
here I'm down two rooks can I checked
him a lot okay
Queen Shak Knight f4 threatening Queenie
to checkmate yeah I have a threat okay
now why did I win this game even though
I'm down to row
because my opponent had seconds and I
had like four minutes so seconds wasn't
enough and he sacrificed for my night
and now it should be a dry thing I could
keep checking him check check check
check check but instead of perpetual
check he hung meat in one yeah
also he tried not to hang meat in one he
like mean it he's like nah that's okay
I'll go there he's like okay so he made
the move that hung meat and one then he
put it back cuz his hand was still on it
and I was like oh well he saw that he
did anyway so play king e4 black
checkmates in one move who can find it
other than Julian and if you're a chess
student you should always meet your
opponent one because then you win yeah
mate yeah so I won yeah if he plays King
g4 then I don't know I'd have to Houdini
it but probably it's a draw I could
probably just keep checking him you
Queen G to take on anyone
well now I'm down a piece so and this
piece is hanging whoa but you but but I
mean you're down you're down a piece
what are you down your piece
this should be six checks won't no I
would have won I'm not saying I wouldn't
won but I drill is yeah no I'm saying
with correct play I should draw but
since he has seconds I'll probably
suspiciously play on yeah and yeah these
tricks don't work at my last round
Isabel how could you lose the last round
like that okay see totally forgot all
right now the last round was against
priyadarshan who's our hero in fact he's
probably playing upstairs right now or
maybe later when do they start okay they
started oh so he's playing right now
unless he's not playing okay
now what's funny about this is after I
lost this game and I hung my head in
shame and I walked home and like people
at the bars were like laughing at me
employee then I I noticed that chest
komm put my latest lecture up and it was
on this opening I was like but I won
that game in nineteen dollars no 1,300
okay so my opponent played the Queens
gambit accepted this is actually quite
funny I had a student over my house a
few days ago and I said what's this
opening called I thought he'd say like
the grünfeld or you know the the real
hope has you know some normal answer and
he said this is the Queens gambit
accepted I was like wow it didn't even
happen and he's right like this is just
this is just the Queens gambit but he
knew the guy took I guess I think that's
like okay okay so in this position here
White has many moves Bishop d3
a 4d takes e5 Queen e2 I play Bishop d3
which I played in 1989 and put a lecture
on chess calm recently so so this is
still my game with this is still my game
with with from chess comm lecture and my
game last week now well this is sort of
boring but we'll do a little tactics
because tactics are fun for intermediate
players let's say black wins upon whoo
right Isabel then and then we take and
take and then Nikki is going to show the
winning move for white winning a queen
white wins a queen don't it's a queen
Bishop c5 check I knew what you meant
this should be front Shack and you
attacked the Queen right so did pre dart
should do that and I want $86 there's an
alternate universe where that happened
okay it's a great universe okay anyway
he didn't do that
okay now if it was his move he still
couldn't do it because Bishop takes h7
Shack and I still take his queen so he's
never threading that pawn okay now when
he played b6 which he did right what did
I think he was gonna do next to move
that's what I thought but he didn't do
that he put another idea which we see in
the Smith Morra gambit and I wrote a
book on that from blacks point of view
so I should know this idea rook a7 and
the idea is to play rugby
and then take my D pawn at some point
and that's what happened now there's a
funny draw now priyadarshan is an
international master he was a grand
master we would have had a Grand Master
draw but he's not a grand master he
would have played Knight takes d4 and
then I would play 95 attacking his Iraq
and then we would have drawn out of an
awesome then we would have shared first
place okay but he played Bishop d7 Queen
f4 and usually this is good for whites
again an attack all my pieces are
attacking his King but if you make two
blunders in a row then you don't do so
well okay and that's what I did and I
got to this position and probably the
best move his Bishop to e4 probably but
I sacrificed upon because I was
overconfident d5 blocking two of his
pieces he took now his Bishop isn't
crushing me and his rook isn't crushing
me although I am down upon okay and I
made the losing move and if you're a
chess student and you want to avoid
losing you should write this down don't
make the losing wolf terrible and I've
lectured about this kind of blunder many
times but I still make it okay now I
played the aggressive move G for
attacking the knight and I thought he
had three moves Knight g7 Knight f6 or
Bishop takes Bishop after Knight f6 I
would sacrifice on e7 and then I would
capture this guy for free and after
Knight g7 I figure I would check made
him somehow
you know like Queen aged six and then I
would trade bishops on e7 and play
Knight g5 okay and then Bishop takes
Bishop I thought was his best move
instead he won the game immediately
although the game took another 50 moves
raise your hand if you have a question
okay this isn't Soviet Russia or wait a
minute all right
maybe it is so so here's the problem
g4 weakens my night because it was
defended and now it's not also if my
knight disappeared which I can do ha
didn't see
Hey didn't see that coming if the night
disappears up there it is then he could
take my bishop for free so I I'm
defended by night and I need my knight
there so he attacked my knight I didn't
see that okay and then right after I
moved and he had the hand to moving like
he was gonna crush me get that movement
like ah I he had the movement was gonna
crush me and he played what move can
West attacking tonight that was the end
you can do it he's like you can't attack
the knight impossible
Knight to d4 yeah unfortunate now he's
threatening this with advantage and if
my knight moves away my bishop on g5 is
hanging so I'm losing that's tough
so I took he took I'm lucky my Queens
not trapped and black is a pawn up with
a better position and we got to some
position like this and then I'm down
upon my opponent has two bishops if you
remember the first game of the lecture
and you don't but if you did you'll
remember I had two knights against two
bishops and I won that game
now what opening do I play with black
where you often get two knights against
two bishops chigorin right and which
grandmaster who's one of the top 20
players in the world is the only one who
doesn't dislike nights over bishops he
lives in st. Louis who Nakamura
he thinks Knights are great other
grandmasters like two bishops for
example in the US championship last year
2012 there was the game owners shook
Nakamura and in that game was two
knights against two bishops and then
honest looks like I got two bishops
right so now he does you have two
bishops but he has an extra pawn I also
like Kings a little funny and this game
went on and on and on and on I was
trying to equalize but I never did and
then I had five seconds left and he had
a minute and a half and I said well
there's no stay
here so I resigned because I was down
like seven pieces but okay I lost that
game basically because I played this
stupid Muji for terrible and then he got
all the money and I got 86th because 86
was first ah terrible right you agree so
if you're here in the audience or if
you're there if you come to the Chess
Club of the month of October which is
now there's a lot of money added to the
Friday action quads there's an extra $50
per quod extra yeah you see and if you
pay a $10 entry fee first prize in your
quad is $86 reasonable for quad and
there's a random raffle for no reason
before the last round for $100 like
here's $100 and I didn't win that that
sounds going for so I didn't win that
that was unfortunate so I planted in the
quad which I never played in and now you
know why because I got beat okay
terrible and praetorship plays in the
quads a lot and he beats everybody and
he plays in the u.s. chest league and he
beats everybody and then I give lectures
okay but I can show you games from 1935
where I beat everybody that was good
then right
no not here I was terrible right yeah
and to finish select shock lay something
funny about 1963 because that would make
sense
in 1989 I played Judit Polgar and she
beat me when the game ended she said
excuse me while I whip this out and she
took out all these papers and they were
all my games because the computers in 89
were iffy but she printed out stuff and
she's and she was showing me my game and
she said I don't understand this game
and it was the game fisher feingold 1963
she was like well you were born in 69
and I said I was really good in 63 and I
so that's my dad she said oh okay I
could understand yeah and then in 1980
they don't know six probably and in 1986
or so I played a guy and he beat me of
course he was like 300 points low rated
that he's like I played you 25 years ago
and I said I'm 23 like I should do that
I said you probably played my dad he's
like your dad okay I don't know and my
dad's like yeah I plug that guy so yeah
my dad and my brother and myself we're
all over 2200 or were
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
[Music]